je trouve que ça part de manière un peu
trop nervée parce que justement ah à
propos de vous euh c'est vrai que vous
avez fait l'émission de Jordan Deluxe et
vous avez dit en gros bah depuis que
j'ai soutenu Zemmour les propositions de
travail se font beaucoup plus rares mais
c'est là où je me dis quand même vous
êtes extrêmement intelligent vous êtes
cultivé vous savez comment tout ça
marche donc vous savez très bien que par
exemple en soutenance Zemmour ou en vous
levant de table c'est des instants qu'on
pourra passer face à bellata en voulant
rentable en lisant je vais te péter la
gueule vous savez qu'en faisant tout ça
ça va créer une espèce de buzz autour de
vous qui peut être plus ou moins négatif
qui peut faire peur aux chaînes vous
connaissez le système vous saviez par
exemple quand soutenant Zemmour tous
ceux qui l'ont fait avant vous que ce
soit le type qui était le chevalier par
la falaise Philippe chevalier que ce
soit les rouquestres Jean Roucas à
l'époque tous ceux qui ont soutenu
l'extrême en jette des parties extrêmes
en général derrière on était boycoté il
faut tout reprendre dans l'ordre
mettons de côté Bellatar parce que je
regrette de mettre levé mais je ne
mesure pas le buzz parce que vous péter
un plomb vous pétez un plomb c'est vrai
ce type me traite de fasciste trois fois
la troisième c'était trop je l'avais
averti je mets ça de côté c'est un coup
de nerf un coup de sang je le regrette
parce qu'il n'en vaut pas la peine
d'accord ensuite je vais essayer d'être
honnête et précis mais ennuie en
commençait avant Zemmour j'ai été
chroniqueur On n'est pas couché j'ai dit
ce que je pensais sur beaucoup
d'artistes il en est né pas mal de
rancune pas mal de rancoeurs et de
ressentiments et je vais vous confier
quelque chose je crois que je l'ai
jamais raconté un jour je passe un
pilote pour une émission culturelle il y
a plusieurs années pour l'émission la
grande émission culturelle de France 2
qui passait le jeudi soir en deuxième
partie de soirée ou le vendredi soir ils
avaient changé de cage je ne sais plus
il y a des gens de France 2 qui
assistent au pilotes qui sont
extrêmement enthousiastes pas positif
enthousiaste pour moi l'affaire est
faite bien sûr or je sais
que immédiatement quand le bruit s'est
répandu des gens ont appelé la chaîne
pour leur dire que c'était un scandale
de me confier une émission culturelle
après tout ce que j'avais fait sur le
plateau n'en est pas couché où j'avais
dézingué machin dézingué machines donc
ça c'est le début de mes ennuis il y a
même insérer producteur qui a écrit une
lettre donc j'ai vu cette lettre il a
écrit une lettre à la direction de
France 2 pour dire c'était un scandale
donc ça a commencé avant ensuite il y a
la faire Zemo alors juste à parler avant
parce que moi pardon je vais faire
l'avocat du diable mais vous avez été 10
12 chroniqueurs dans cette émission
Natacha Polony et d'autres tout sont
retrouvés du travail ou alors on fait de
la politique mais tout son travail
derrière n'ont pas été boycoté pourquoi
vous non mais moi j'ai trouvé du boulot
j'ai jamais eu un plaindre oui mais
c'est plus difficile de pas trouver du
boulot quand vous sortez dans On n'est
pas couché que d'en trouver parce que
vous êtes quand même très exposés je
vous dis simplement que dans ce cas je
sais que des gens et je sais même qui
sont ces gens ah oui appeler la
direction
ça c'est la première partie donc
j'essaie d'être précis ensuite il y a
l'affaire Zemmour
moi je calcule pas est-ce que c'est bon
pour ma carrière est-ce que c'est pas
bon pour ma carrière il est pas question
que je renie un ami pour quelques
raisons que ce soit c'est un ami de
longue date c'est un ami que j'espère
que nous resterons
vas-y quand même il y a des tas de
choses avec lesquelles je ne suis pas
d'accord je ne suis pas d'accord sur le
dossier russe pas plus que je ne suis
d'accord avec ce que vous avez dit
puisque vous êtes un peu mais je ne vous
en avez pas
un meeting
je vous en veux pas chacun votre ce
qu'il veut mais derrière vous savez qu'à
partir du moment où vous êtes dans cette
niche là vous allez de toute manière
vous mettre une partie de l'opinion ou
une partie des dirigeants ados vous le
savez ça j'ai un ami de longue date qui
se porte candidat à la présidentielle ça
arrive pas tous les jours non il fait il
fait un meeting qui était l'événement du
moment j'ai jamais connu une ambiance
pareille c'était cerné de flics il y
avait 10 000 personnes de football il me
semble que ma place d'amis et ma place
de journaliste non et dans ce ben si moi
je vous le dis on a peut-être pas on a
peut-être pas la même conception du
journaliste surtout que vous vous ne
l'êtes pas et moi je le suis donc c'est
peut-être ça qui nous différencie aussi
est-ce que vous dit simplement que en
tant qu'ami et en tant que journaliste
ma place était là ensuite si j'avais
voulu être le soutien de Zemmour je
serai monté à la tribune et j'aurais
soutenu est-ce que j'ai fait une
déclaration orale en disant je soutiens
la candidature non est-ce que j'ai fait
une déclaration écrite non est-ce que
j'ai été dans un soutien c'est pareil
lui pour le soutenir mais c'est pas
encore une fois ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas vrai qu'il était le soutien
c'est mon ami je défends mes amis il a
jamais dit qu'il était son soutien
c'était mon ami c'est mon ami ce sera
mon ami voilà il y a quelqu'un c'est
vraiment le soutenir c'est dire allez
par exemple la meeting monter
effectivement sur scène faire des vidéos
pour cette personne
c'était intéressé par certaines parties
de son discours Mathieu
Eric nolo ça a été pendant des années le
meilleur contradicteur d'Éric Zemmour
une fois que je vois pas à quel moment
il y a un soutien politique on parle de
politique il y a pas politique
Eric Naulleau c'est un homme de gauche
donc à quel moment alors effectivement
de gauche d'abord
il faut lire son bouquin avec Michel
Onfray qui est vachement bien foutu
d'ailleurs du reste sur la gauche
réfractaire
dans la semaine mais c'est très
intéressant
on va pas se dire le contraire en fait
on regardait nolo et Zemmour pour ça
parce que justement il y avait une
écoute justement il y avait une
véritable sémantique il y avait une
manière de jouer sur les mots de se
comprendre et de s'écouter à aucun
moment Éric Naulleau n'a soutenu
politiquement Zemmour
ça serait bien de ramener le débat sur
le sujet qui fait qu'on a nos invités
aujourd'hui non mais bien que j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont pas le même
témoignage du tout
Eric c'est autre chose
Eric il vient pour dire on me propose
rien à la télé aujourd'hui pour
reprendre la phrase que tu viens de dire
parce que mes engagements parce que ma
gueule etc c'est le titre du thème moi
la question que je veux poser Eric c'est
en vrai tu étais avant de faire la télé
avant l'histoire avec Laurent Ruquier
éditeur vous avez jamais fait de télé de
ta vie c'était pas une star et cetera tu
as été médiatisé ou combien était très
brillante exercice qu'est-ce qui fait
que à moins tu penses que tout ça c'est
à qui et que tu devrais avoir une
émission à la télé de culture parce que
c'est un peu ce que tu dis chez Jordan
je dis quelque chose
il y a tout un tas de gens talentueux
j'ai fait 20 ans à TF1 j'ai arrêté
pendant 15 ans et jamais tu m'as tenu tu
m'as entendu tu me rendes morales
attendu de tenir à propos qui consiste à
dire bah pourquoi plus moi aujourd'hui
pourquoi je suis pas légitime à parce
que si c'est une façon de dire je suis
légitime à faire une émission culturelle
on la propose pas je précise non alors
je dois peut-être préciser et élargir
mon propos je trouve très curieux mais
c'est peut-être une simple coïncidence
que depuis l'affaire Zemmour par exemple
reprenons à partir de zéro alors je
parle même pas d'avoir une émission je
ne jamais invité à quelques titres que
je sois sur le service public c'est
peut-être une coïncidence jamais sur les
chaînes publiques de radio jamais sur
les chaînes publiques de télévision
peut-être que vous allez m'expliquer que
au fond il y a des coïncidences dans la
vie et que c'est le rythme de la grange
mais moi je trouve qu'on esquive le
véritable le véritable sujet de notre
débat il se trouve que j'ai à faire et
Véronique aussi je pense dans une
certaine mesure j'ai affaire à
l'intolérance de gens qui sont des
professionnels de la tolérance
c'est-à-dire que toute la journée se
réclame de la tolérance disent qu'il
faut débattre mais ne veulent pas
débattre avec des gens qui ne sont pas
d'accord avec eux c'est ça le cœur du
problème on ne débat plus qu'avec des
gens dans un spectre politique ou un
spectre idéologique extrêmement réduit
vous n'allez pas chercher aux extrêmes
parce que vous ne voulez pas vous
confronter à des opinions
contradictoires c'est ça le problème et
dès que vous sortez du cadre et bien
vous n'êtes plus dans votre cas d'accord
parce que moi j'ai une journaliste mais
dans le cadre de Véronique Véronique je
peux comprendre une chose c'est que une
chaîne qui vend une chaîne ou un
producteur de cinéma ce que tu veux qui
veut partager Véronique il engage une
actrice il engage pas quelqu'un qui est
là pour donner ses opinions il n'engage
pas quelqu'un qui va forcément risquer
de diviser de scinder le public tu vois
ce que je veux dire c'est en ça que je
me dis est-ce que les artistes doivent
prendre la parole ou pas surtout que la
vôtre elle est pas elle est pas douce de
parole très honnêtement moi elle l'a
jamais été douce ma parole moi avant de
faire Julie Lescaut mais parce que vous
entendez moi quand même avant
les réseaux sociaux
ne voulait pas de moi parce que j'étais
une grande gueule et que je j'étais pas
banquier belle il disait à l'époque un
jour du jour au lendemain j'ai été
banquable pourquoi parce que j'avais
besoin de moi donc je suis devenue
ma gueule jamais
vu il y avait pas tweet mais en fait je
vous ai jamais vu dans une émission de
télé
à l'époque venir parler de vos opinions
sur toutes les semaines
parce que j'avais dit un truc sur sur un
imitateur que je trouvais nul alors
j'étais convoqué j'étais dans mais
attendez vous allez me calmer chez des
échanges un peu mais ça il y avait
encore des gens intelligents à TF1 donc
ça allait non mais c'est vrai il y avait
encore des gens qui qui n'étaient pas
comment vous dire il y a une sorte de on
n'a pas non c'était pas mieux oui oui
quand même c'était mieux
les Grandes Gueules ou pas on avait des
projets on faisait des choses et on
était écouté moi je suis pas là pour
faire là où on dit de faire j'ai jamais
été je ne le supporte pas non le vrai
problème aujourd'hui il est pas ça il
est pas qu'on veuille pas de nous il est
ce qu'on nous propose moi ce qu'on me
propose ne m'intéresse pas oui mais ça
c'est un autre sujet mais par exemple
notre sujet
l'histoire tu vas accueillir tes
pâquerettes dans ton champ et tu
profites que tu as gagné
c'est une possibilité
il y en a pas une je viens de refuser
hier de faire une pièce en septembre
2023 ça ne m'intéresse pas d'accord donc
à tous ceux qui vont à ceux qui nous
regardent que ce soit à la télévision ou
au cinéma ne faites pas de propositions
à Véronique ça ne vous intéresse pas
je ferai des choses le jour où les
propositions m'intéressent moi j'ai 30
ans mais je fais je développe des
projets
j'aimerais dire aussi un mot Éric le
vrai des questions mais aussi
que elle et fille c'est pas votre truc
vous tapez vous tapez dessus en
permanence donc c'est vrai aussi que
vous donnez tellement votre opinion
qu'aujourd'hui comment vous avoir par
exemple sur Europe 1 ou n'importe quoi
on connaît quasiment toutes vos opinions
donc forcément on sait que vous n'êtes
pas neutre vous connaissez pas les
opinions des autres journalistes
là-bas à l'époque il avait la passe ton
temps à dire que non non
vous êtes sûr parce que en tous les cas
nous quand Georges marchait sans prendre
noément à Elkabbache vous croyez pas que
c'est sur la base des opinions
politiques la connaît et que tout le
monde connaît non excusez-moi mais je
voudrais que ça soit clair moi je suis
pas dans le ressentiment ou dans la
demande moi je suis très heureux chez
moi avec mes chats mes livres et une
tasse de café
non c'est pas ça simplement j'entends
une petite musique dans cette émission à
savoir qu'il est normal que sur la base
d'opinion divergente Véronique ne trouve
pas de boulot ou en tout cas pas de ne
reçoivent pas de de propositions assez
intéressantes et que moi non plus il y a
un truc qui m'échappe dans ce
raisonnement il me semble que ça devrait
se jouer ailleurs apparemment non
personne pas bien quand on ne pense pas
personnaliser
vous vous engagez vous donnez votre
opinion mais heureusement que je donne
mon opinion dans une heure heureusement
que je donne mon opinion dans une
émission de débat politique heureusement
[Applaudissements]